okay everybody get ready to take notes i
spoke to clark county credit union about
ways they're giving back
and some really great tips on how to
smart how to shop smart
this holiday season check it out happy
bonus days right
yes happy bonus days that is correct so
let's explain that to our viewers what
does that mean
that means we're going to be giving back
to both the community in general and
also five of our members randomly
and uh yeah and i'll talk a little bit
about how about that
awesome so let's start with the first
question here how can people be
aware of their spending habits during
the holidays and be safe when they're
doing it
the old-fashioned tried and true budget
so if you know you're going to be
exchanging gifts this year
first thing is make a list of the people
you want to buy gifts for check that
list twice so you don't overlook anybody
because if you overlook somebody then
you could be buying last minute gifts
that will throw you over your budget
once you've got your list finalized
assign
a budget to each gift and then the
tricky part
is to stick with it if you can stay with
that budget
you can have a great holiday season and
not acquire a whole lot of new debt in
the process
it's a talent to know how to stick to a
budget and what is clark county credit
union doing um to make this season you
know a little brighter for everybody
since it's
yes we are we are going to be honoring
five non-profit charities during our
happy bonus
days event from december 7th through
december 11th
uh that week a charity a day will be
recognized with a 1500
donation from clark county credit union
the charities that we have selected are
uh ronald mcdonald house candlelighters
juvenile diabetes foundation
um three square and help for southern
nevada
and we're also that we going to be
randomly paying down
five of our uh clark county credit
members credit cards by up to fifteen
hundred dollars so we're gonna pick one
member each one of those days
and uh so if a member uses their clark
county credit union card
uh bring up from black friday
through cyber monday that will count as
an entry into this random drawing
that definitely is a happy bonus day of
course you're encouraging your members
to use their cccu credit cards
to enter for this amazing prize but is
it safe to use your credit cards right
now during the holidays
that's a great question and it's
actually using your credit card can be a
very helpful way to manage your finances
if you're the type of person that can
stick to a budget
and pay down your balances monthly do
you have any tips or suggestions as
people start their holiday shopping
absolutely the key to uh successful
savings is planning ahead so
some of this you can use this year so
that you're gonna use next year but when
you know you're gonna be buying gifts
for people of course keep track of who
you're buying for
and buy the gifts early if you can that
way you're spreading your budget out
over
many paychecks instead of just the last
few before the holidays and if you buy a
gift early and you wrap it make sure you
track it
you can use a spreadsheet you can use
the note system on your phone but
that way you don't forget who you bought
what for so you're not buying gifts
later that throw you over your budget
also a great thing for giving is the
gift of savings that you can open an
account for your child or your
grandchild a youth account
not only will that account grow with
them throughout their life it puts them
on the path of financial literacy
and another thing we have is the
christmas club account you can start
this as early as january if you want
and it builds up all year long for more
information call 702-228-2228 or visit
ccculv.org and don't forget use the cccu
credit card between black friday and
cyber monday
to enter to win their bonus days contest
we'll be right back